El conductor hace algunas de las entregas
y los drones van y vienen, haciendo otras mientras el camión se mueve.
De esa forma, el coste por entrega baja
y voilà,
servicios de comercio electrónico, baratos, en el campo.
Ya lo verán,
los nuevos hogares de nuestros teletrabajadores
probablemente tendrán una pista de aterrizaje para drones en el patio.
Una vez que la distribución capilar no sea problema,
ya no se necesitará estar en la ciudad para comprar cosas.
Y van dos.
Ahora, veamos la tercera razón:
una intensa vida social.
¿Hace falta estar en la ciudad para eso?
Porque hoy en día,
la gente hace amistades, chatea, cotillea y liga
desde el confort de su sofá,
(Risas)
y en pijama.
Hay 2000 millones de usuarios de redes sociales activos en el mundo.
De alguna forma, parece indicar que estamos conectados,
sin importar dónde estemos.
Pero vale, no del todo.
También necesitamos contacto humano real.
Irónicamente, la ciudad y su densidad de población
no siempre es lo mejor para eso.
De hecho, a medida que los grupos sociales se hacen más pequeños,
se hacen también más fuertes.
Un estudio reciente hecho en el Reino Unido
por la Oficina de Estadística Nacional
muestra un mayor grado de satisfacción
en las personas que viven en zonas rurales.
Y a medida que más gente se muda al campo,
necesitarán alimentos,
frutas, verduras
y servicios de mantenimiento.
Se necesitarán pequeños talleres, compañías de servicios y manitas.
Quizá, algunos de los trabajadores
desplazados por la automatización industrial en las ciudades,
encontrarán oportunidades de empleo aquí,
y se mudarán también.
Si la gente empieza a mudarse al campo,
¿cómo cambiarían las cosas?
Piensa en chalets autónomos,
desconectados de la red eléctrica, con paneles solares,
generadores eólicos y sistemas de reciclaje de resíduos.
Nuevos hogares produciendo energía y recargando el auto familiar.
Las ciudades siempre se han visto como más eficientes energéticamente,
pero repoblar el campo
también puede ser “ecológico”.
Y, probablemente ahora estés pensando en las ventajas de vivir en el campo.
(Risas)
A mí me pasó.
Hace seis años, mi mujer y yo empaquetamos todo.
Vendimos nuestro pequeño apartamento en España,
y por el mismo dinero nos compramos un chalet. Con jardín.
Y pequeños pajaritos que vienen a cantarnos por las mañanas.
(Risas)
Se está muy bien aquí.
Y eso que vivimos en un pueblo pequeño, no en el campo.
Ese va a ser mi próximo paso.
Una granja restaurada.
No demasiado lejos de una ciudad, pero no demasiado cerca.
Y me aseguraré de tener un buen sitio para que aterrizen los drones.
(Risas)
Pero, ese soy yo.
No tiene por qué ser para Uds.
Porque podría parecer que estoy intentando convencer a alguien
de que se venga al campo.
Para nada.
(Risas)
No necesito que venga más gente.
Solo pienso que lo harán,
cuando se den cuenta de que pueden tener las ventajas de la ciudad.
Pero si no les gusta el campo,
también tengo buenas noticias.
Las ciudades no van a desaparecer,
pero a medida que la gente se vaya,
una densidad menor les ayudará a recuperar su balance.
En fin, imagino que les he dado algo en lo que pensar:
¿Aún creen que tienen que vivir en la ciudad?
Y lo que es más importante:
¿Quieren?
¡Muchas gracias!
(Aplausos)